for days ment and her family have
been watching Kenyan police and forest
rangers setting her neighbor's homes on
fire across the Valley from where she
lives she's wondering if her home will
be next the government says people here
are living illegally in a Forest Reserve
then security officers
arrive the police chief says we will not
leave a single house
here I feel I have nowhere else to go
they're not respecting anyone's rights
they're just burning
houses government eviction guidelines
say residents should be compensated and
given 3 months
notice this happened in
minutes and it's a similar story all the
way down the Valley Community leaders
say more than 160 homes have been
destroyed in the last week Rangers have
beaten people and thousands are being
made homeless the environment ministry
didn't respond to our request for
comment the people who lived in this
home told us that their fam's been here
for Generations since before
independence from British colonial rule
but the government says this is
necessary to protect one of Kenya's most
important water
sources the Mau Forest is the largest
highland tropical forest in East Africa
the rainfall Court here feeds more than
a dozen rivers and six major Lakes an
estimated 10 million people depend on it
down on the plains farmers and herders
have been struggling with reducing water
levels for years scientists say that's
because more than a quarter of the
forest has been destroyed since the
1990s mainly by growing human
settlements last week President William
Ruto said the government will regenerate
it with help from foreign donors and so
the people have to
go those who left voluntarily we will
relocate them but those who are still in
the forest Now sort yourselves out very
fast and leave because we are going to
put off
fence Ruto is among politicians who
encouraged people to settle in the
forest in the
1990s right groups say some of them made
money from selling a regular Land Titles
the forest's been shrinking rapidly ever
since Kim Anish says she was born
here 60 years ago in the 1980s the
government told her community they were
outside the Forest Reserve and issued
numbers for their plots of land now her
home's in
ashes we know the forest boundary is
half a kilometer away from here the
government's ignored the boundary and
taken our land it's important to
preserve the environment but this is not
the right way to do it previous rounds
of evictions have also been marred by
reports of Rights abuses none of them
have stopped the destruction of the
forest Malcolm web Al
noro County
Kenya make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
alaz